-Performing
"Searching for My Love"
from their new album,
"Raise the Roof,"
here's Robert Plant
and Alison Krauss.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
♪♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ Yes, I am ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ Yes, I am ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
♪ Searchin', searchin'
-♪ I'm searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
♪ I'm searchin', searchin'
for my love ♪
♪ Searchin'
for the one that I adore ♪
♪ And if I find her,
you know I will ♪
♪ I'll never let her
go now, baby ♪
♪ No, no, no, no, no ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ I'll never let her
go now, baby ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ I love you ♪
♪ I need you ♪
♪ I'll need you by my side ♪
♪ For my love ♪
♪ My own true love ♪
-♪ I'll never, never hide,
now, baby ♪
♪ No, no, no, no, no ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ I'll never, never hide,
now, baby ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ Oh, no ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ No, no ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-Oh!
♪ I wonder, oh ♪
♪ I wonder why you had
to leave me this way ♪
♪ I'm sorry, darling ♪
♪ Oh, that I made you cry ♪
♪ Forgive me, love, mm ♪
♪ For the things
I've done to you ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Come on, come on ♪
♪ Come on,
give me one more try ♪
♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Searchin', baby ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ I'm searchin', searchin'
for my love ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ Searchin'
for the one that I adore ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ When I find her ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ I'll never let her
go now, baby.
♪ No, no, no, no, no ♪
-♪ Searchin', searchin'
for my baby ♪
-♪ I'll never let her
go now, baby.
♪ Oh ♪
-♪ No, no, no, no, no, no, no ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]